so I love this genre of Storytelling and
I specifically love how Millennial uh
the recruit feels and so I'm really
curious to know how uh did the story
come to you in this cast of characters
come to you I mean ultimately it came to
me first through the idea of greymail
which is blackmail with National
Security this idea that there are people
out there who are trying to Blackmail
the government the CIA specifically
because they say they know Secrets most
of them are they don't they're sort of
they call them the crazies for a reason
um but that seemed like a really fun way
in and fresh way into the world and then
in terms of the Millennials I mean that
was to me the heart of the show is that
instead of coming at it through you you
know a 30-something-year-old spy who's
really good at his job to come at it
through a kid right at a law school who
doesn't you know is barely you know
gotten his jacket off before he starts
down this Rabbit Hole you know but who
has roommates who has complicated
relationships who has you know romance
and all that stuff also felt like a
fresh take on the on on a spy show no
one was Doug Lyman brought in well it we
set it up ultimately I mean with Doug's
company hypnotic so Doug was involved
from the very beginning the question
always is with a incredibly busy uh
directors are are is he going to be
available to actually do it and so you
know luckily for us the Stars aligned
and his schedule opened up and so but
yeah no he was involved from the very
beginning so I was a huge fan of Castle
and I know you've worked with Nathan
Fillion obviously on the rookie so we
have to talk about that Cameo how did
that come to be was it like an instant
yes with Nathan it was I called him I
said hey will you and before I even
finished the sentence he said yes
because Nathan is such a great guy
um but I just thought you know this CIA
director is coming in at the last minute
of the show really of the first season
and he's got to come in and like own the
room and you know and Nathan is just
such a great actor and so charismatic
but also and he got excited because he's
like I get to curse which he never gets
to do on network television so yeah it
was super fun and you you know I was
grateful for him saying yes like that
were there any scenes that ended up
changing whether it be when like a new
location was found or something changing
like on the day I'm always so interested
to see how things changed once you're
actually in the location I mean we were
shooting up in Montreal over winter
which is you know at best freezing and
at worst like negative 20. so there were
a lot of adjustments that had to be made
over time we also had planned to do a
lot of shooting overseas on location and
covid really hurt us on that you know we
were going to go to Morocco for some
stuff but they literally closed their
borders because of covid and so we ended
up having to make adjustments and shoot
a lot of stuff in Montreal and just you
know there is definitely a visual
effects component of it but in a way
that's meant not to be noticed you know
sometimes that stuff's supposed to be
flashy but for us it's like the black
site in Yemen we shot in a parking lot
in Montreal at the sound stages and the
the world around it is created but you
know again in a way that that's seamless
think a little bit about the
cat were just wonderful
s where they
for those roles like specifically or was
it through uh you know an audition
process so Noah attached
um before we took it out to Netflix to
sell it to Netflix you know we brought
him on board super early it's obviously
very important in this day and age to
find a star for your show it gives you
the most chance of success and you know
um it's rare that the people that you
love and really want to get are
available the same thing with Doug and
but we got lucky and he was available
and he loved the script and so he came
on board and then it was just a question
of finding the right people and you know
Noah is an executive producer on the
show and he was very involved in the
casting process and you know it was very
generous with his time like he would
read with the actors and do chemistry
reads and you know because it was
important to surround him because even
though he is the lead of the show there
is a strong Ensemble and we found
phenomenal actors to fill those roles
and so you know it's just it was a lot
of fun to go through that process with
him the ending of the Season had me
wanting to like find a number to call
not Netflix looks and be like you have
to renew this for a second season it was
just so good how far out do you have
this mapped out you know I know things
about where I would want to take it and
where I want I'd want to go with it I
mean obviously you hope for Success
um but I you know as as you could see
with that ending like I you know I
didn't plan for failure because I feel
like in this day and age you just have
to be bold you have to be dramatic and
you know and to the expense of
everything else and you can't worry
about season twos or season threes or
Beyond you have to go what's the best
version of the story right now and and
and trust that people will come to it
and they'll they'll everybody will you
know and then you'll get another shot at
it uh can we actually talk about that
Cliffhanger ending and the way it all
kind of comes together I went back and
re-watched some of the previous episodes
just to like see where things are like
slowly working towards that but can you
talk a little bit about the process of
building to that like jaw dropping
finale yeah I mean it was important to
really sort of lay the breadcrumbs
really early I mean you notice in in
episode two Max when she's threatening
yudira the woman who tried to shank or
in prison in bed she's talked she's
talking about her daughter in a way
that's organic the way that's connecting
because it's involved with the threat
you have a daughter I have a daughter
that kind of thing and just really to
subtly lay those those groundworks and
also you know the need to go of it all
and and you know the CIA office when
they're going through who who we got to
kill and who we don't have to kill and
all that kind of stuff and so yeah I
mean because we knew where we were going
we we managed to find all those these
little places to sort of move that story
so it felt inevitable even though it was
shocking and unexpected the second it
happened it it doesn't come out of
nowhere it's just you you didn't have
enough information so because you know I
think audiences hate being surprised but
it not being earned can you talk about
anything that you were surprised by or
learned during the process because
obviously you talked a little bit about
like this being filmed during coven that
was such a brand new era of you know
filmmaking for a lot of people so can
you talk a little bit about that yeah I
mean I had had the benefit of of having
done the rookie um from the very
beginning of covet I mean season three
of the rookie was right when
um cobit had hid and you know we delayed
production trying to figure out how we
were going to make a show in the time
where everybody had to wear masks and
and didn't know anything about it so
that the good news was that I had
experience with that but you know I mean
you know we shot a Montreal and I'd
never sort of shop there before and and
you know and our sets weren't ready
right when they were supposed to be so
there was some scrambling which you know
I mean this is all first year show stuff
this happens all the time but but
there's constantly stuff that you have
to adjust to you just have to try and
keep your head and and just you know go
left when you can't go right excellent
well thank you so much and fingers
crossed on a season two thank you so
much